the war in ukraine new images this
morning of russia's brutal assault on
that country cameras captured the moment
russian troops fired into a crowd of
demonstrators in kirsan that's in
southern ukraine it's a city that
russian troops control but there have
been frequent protests from people who
live there not far away mariupol
continues to be under siege residents
cut off from basic necessities mts tayab
spoke to a family that escaped mary opal
and he continues to join us from la vie
ukraine mtiz good morning
tony good morning well the ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky saying that
russia is really trying to reduce
mariopol to ash as he's described it but
he insists that the city will survive
now here in the vid we had the chance to
meet to a family that has fled that
horrific violence and they've described
it as
hell on earth
this carnage is what's left of the
strategic southern port city of mariupol
where vladimir putin's war on ukraine is
at its most destructive and devastating
triggering a mass exodus some of these
cars have signs reading children taped
to their windows as they escape with
little more than their lives like the
vordezonska family still bloodied and
bruised they fled their home in
marijuana to the safety of this church
in the western city of la vie
once a typical middle class family it
took roman svetlana and their children
five days of traveling by road to escape
russia's relentless bombing of the city
they called home but now described as
hell on earth
hell is when you don't know if you'll be
able to take your next breath if you'll
have anything to feed your children with
because they're hungry she says hell is
when you know that if your child gets
sick he will die
that is hell that is hell here in the
21st century
nearly 90 percent of all buildings and
homes here have been damaged or
destroyed in mariopol according to
ukrainian government officials
video apparently showing tanks firing in
the streets and armed soldiers
patrolling what's left of neighborhoods
in the rush to flee svetlana injured her
head in a car accident while avoiding
russian strikes which have now
completely destroyed their family home
what did you tell your children
the truth the way it is she says they
will be told the russians wanted to kill
us but we persevered because we are
strong
where do you get your strength
we are ukrainians she says
it's in our blood
svelana and her family clearly very
defiant and determined and they say that
they hope the next step in their journey
will lead them to the u.s and to safety
but they say they want the world to know
this they will return to mariupol and
they will rebuild their home
nate
hell on earth that is one way to
describe it and i hope that they find a
little bit of heaven wherever they land
mts tab in western ukraine thank you so
much